прямо робот шу за кілька теж не у нас
починається зони складного тіньування наки
статей підготовка та низка гнулися
Облаву дейліки проти говори та таких
накликав і тільки місяці там так вигляду
гнулась а
і навіть а нам бюджетом передачі не кішки
проведення точно має синього не і
тоді у нас були проблеми з на годину
ністю проплат диких hunky
там уми згорнулася obladi на фонді
ринату ахметова і ми здобули п'ять ринку
це те в годину на все було проплачено а ось
для того щоб вони строчать і темп і
алгоритму де ось цьому всього 1
підготовка до складу не я тесті заново і
відбувається в нормальному режимі
випадково у нас є з і шлюбі ви знаєте
про тещу в криму було за х план про
приміщенні центру нашого регіонального
українського центру оцінювання косиці ти
і ми його переносимо до херсона
випускники скраби не знаємо це і було
прийнята на годинник від остигання
граматики рне зайти і люди волонтери
топтатися петром кого на за чай на але
це відчуваєте кримчан ми йдемо назустріч
всіх харчування та тим хто перекладається на
нальчани яхта приводиться на роботу від
увійти до життя ситуації жителі бувають
контрактники бувають бюджетно китану
різанини різанини ситуації запалюємо нашу
пристрасть я chris cornell травня ось щодо
озоне але складно оцінювання то он і
буде проходити в Херсоні
так як і осі від і так вже ми будемо
віддавати їм ще 2 чим можна весь
проходить це їсть його не їх шивани
закинулася причини до їжі до херсона топ
то в Україні з кладуть тести і все буду
текіс причини в cdn is close to знос
об'єктивно ночувати на причини то ми
додому сідоком вже є де українські
школи в криму чого на ще українську ви
знаєте там крима
накрила хвиля під девізом ось і
ксенофобії
з ще українські досі
кримськотатарські ви на замикаючого і
теон залишите докладно захлопується але
у польську краєнську ось там у на
сьогоднішній день я не готовий сказати
ось які там немає акт робітники про школи
я про класи та українською write це та я
на самому початку розбавляв і своїм
добрим друзям та кримськими татарами
піти йди ти в українських класах сам і
іноді їх тут висять esxi води перекладу
їх у російських вас і я до ситуації за
розлучення ми шляхи до вас і себе ось які то
змінилося і фактично але це закриття
шкіл код та український класі у ванній
дід папірцях а ми оминули хами
захоплення приміщення обидва аж лихом
адже пискуна батьківщини давали дітей
вінджа класу багата
коли гладиш повернула сил україни
кидаються але на тязі повороту я сіла
скажімо так виїжджають ось і викладаєте
але виїжджає накидкою педагогіки та
українці стане так філологи чим вони
the real а також різного роду цикл удачі
і я буваю такою сказати ще наша на бісь
а проблема в тому, а не в тому ще ми винесли
забезпечить їх нормальні проживання та
прослуховування тут кримчан ники виїжджають
screamo
напиши проблема в тому ще без 6
ці мотиви потрібні ще квіти
ван і не в вони не хоче нікуди їхати і
там ще кримські незвичайні речі на і
разом Стефани не хоче в 4 викидати і
у російських початкових закладках криму
тут-то вано і хочеш уці був український
почали заставні з зовсім менше правило
за все менше
ну і сказати за 7 що традиція
початківці свободи слова ось і
економічної свободи я думаю ще не
помолюсь їх що скажу зараз у годину на
кримській відкликана влада від у нормальній
тобто і проблеми і студентам цьому
сьогодні пак вони дозують ставити виду
не дати їй влади заздалегідь у закон про
вичу світло це говориться вже дуже багато
рокки як практично
ось я до вас повернувся через засідання
комітету Верховної Ради
такий баварія законопроектів ще святим
особі радикальна реформа переключається та
центральної ідеї всього законопроекту c та
d університетської автономії автономії
фінансової академічної обов'язково
автономії від професіоналів є
національної ініціюючи класифікацію
принцип його нові органи keys твориться
за когось вам принципами туди будуть
входи ти прямо скажемо і злочинці влада
це та міністерство святі будуть води ти
просто знайти вищих початкових закладі
державних приватних та комунальних будуть
входять ти злочинець або студент
процедури все дуже важливо ось вид
національної академії наук той же
принцип його
менше органу який ми за право джейму за
аналогії та забрати мазохін ними системам
цьому ще кожного закону України
принципі майки свої провали prophecy
називаєш тут такого органу на
відьому вид факу які у нас
буфера ніша і ви знаєте що winfakt
тисяч на ліквідований там ще в інст
громадське міністерство світлозара сц
повний абсурд і адже ми повідомляємо
остеотом ще міністерство свити липовий
на контролі вати до міністерства святі
партнером початкових закладі fm бо чим
свій гай до допомагати їм ніби я дещо
ними і в тому числі
мета законопроекту центральної очікується
ідея кістки
обіцянки кістки конкурентної знатності
українських вищих навчальних закладах від та
і ким і за собою в шутер через право
жити університетської автономії ми даємо
опиши правий і ми даємо прикладаємо вбитий
побачилися види іржаві на самі почали
закони за свою яскравість ви довіряєте всім
векторам тут і дати він не має рації
кому найперсональнішою я довіряю ось і
10 про принцип довіру дуріти дуже
важливо принципі я вже батура позіхання зал
процес дурочка cck ваше ви загадали
2000 всього морозі ви малі тикові
семінарах у кембриджі паб це нях
випробувань університетської автономії
проект від кембриджу вина за родом нам
куди їх шиви хоче реалізувати таки
гарний проект вологи
проект вам для чого потрібно 3 мови від
pcc традиції
інший тип правління люди як видавець
роботи цей проект ось і
і третина ще під йому саду гра без
довіреним а я не чохом ось це мода
віра поважаємо ще одна зі списків також
реформування свити до віри всіх у
серед академічного середовища віра держави
здогадалися нас пологів ще й довірливі
треба тримати цю спрагу
зі студента 3 травня ось від купання такого
закону студентам про та атрибути
producing офісного кольору від у польшу
чеку боготу петань готове межі
визначуваному та студентському саму
роздмухуванні уклали ролі струни з до
самої радість сьогодні теж всякого
дискусію малим та випробувань право на
strike ось задушіть когось то права на
протест так і публічний і ми прийшли до
того ще слово будівельний у роті
живота скільки воно дуже читку каддафі
кованого все-таки strike на налаштування на
самій правоті люди ікеа навіть вигляд
зарплату у конкретному
де на рядовий протирати алея
студенти травень права на протест і cbd
зафіксованого у законі хоча всі
громадян мають право на протез на це я
думаю ще є сенс зараз
зафіксувати
оскільки розгорни авокадо мрію сортів
річ крима студенті мені хитрого і kia
та кембриками часто проте малюється
акмолінської academy хустки маса рідко
так протягувати праворуч там а щоки і
благай sky академії з був дуже виданим
ще будете храм один там зникли
студенти мати права на протест та
студенти наші протестував і за крима
колибу майдан і вони протестували і в тому
числі іван iii на пари не ходив і ось
ліван і путін постраждав і в сибур
дефіцит уже вижив і його там ще я мою
стрибала таки з Франції
Франції на проект і ярлика
традиція публічних студентських
протестів Іван відриваєте та й часто
буває олег вулиці протез і закінчуються
то викл удачі спокійного насичить у 7
віці ці мої студенти то тут ніяких
поправок але ти ще я не бог я не знаю
нагадую не може це ми тут я нюанси а
ми збір time ago
дайте мені hit права та цін навіть провалі
думаємо вищого чого тут не лео вдається
ідеальності папороті міністра
забули аудит міністерство фінансовий та
самому міністерстві
нічого не було жодних серйозних
порушень там ще у самому міністерстві
факти звідти 30-ки кішки на заробітну
плату ще дикі кішки зате ми перейшли
нашу бухгалтерію переклали на
вона стала електронною було по 1 від і ми
за право на таку програму ще все
транзакції ківі здійснюються міністерство
їх можна веселить когось в інтернеті
радий жінок менше маса роботи від
очевидно ви в минулому це на уазі схема
різанини кибла від і кольором усіма видами
живлення там ще батут уже журналісти
прогав і проектує на cm засіки друг
підручнику
була маса порушена скажемо погано барні
100 за
при значенні за захист та дисертацію за
життя різанини такі мови схрестила плід
цієї ось я
перше першить і ж не доєна земля всіма
з кризи recall та шоу міністерство
міністерство sweet історія така
ситуація ще там все зійшлося платити
і церес не любить еріка ви від текіла то
є це зачистило місто друзів за
чистилася тут можна сказати ще ми
запитали у нас правоохорони морганом і від
ми передаємо а матеріали до прокуратури
проблемам матеріали
службу bespeco bespeco та україни по
рушниця не було пару дружина брата
кримінальні довідки за раз
приварити ми не боїмося реала ти на все
скарги
у всіх регіонах нехай їх початкових
закладок навчаються нелегко
від наносите різанини та юридичної компанії
адже кіно за пропливали нам допомогу на
волонтерські засідки якісь у нас будуть
ці спеціальні такі різні ситуації
ми набридло близько що він ну та допоможуть
їм людям миг і постраждав і в нас я але
адже такі світла ніяких ховалися за
махини княжити а через того, хто стоїть не
змогли зібрати ту частину колективної
схема на більш серйозний друг
підручний кевін оборони Росії разом з
Беном дуже багато було
був випробуваний з цими не в будинок вона ж
приватизації пляшки з доходом і я був
приватизована була приватизована
key
до пляшки вина лежить міністерства в тому
числі на вулиці сагайдачного
ну самому центрі крику пляшки тут-то
махінації було дуже багато
і ми без льодкова йому друг підручнику
виду на стику було за день івану та каїду
повернення в душі складне харчування і ми
на мага лисиці ви вирішите і наскоком топ
то все кажуть ми ще не все очевидніше
мови дуже ви
і колими починав і по чоловік
допитуватися в чому в дружини очевидніше
виявила сиджу ціни зовсім так там розум і
доступному ж ти не будемо створі в цій
спеціальну комісію з розслідування з
підручний як ви щоразу нічого
1000 вже не просив ці схеми не
проти lg для того, щоб тут висновок а
ще було зручно але я skoda був
нанесено і я класно вигнав із системи
ми будемо створі у цю спеціальну
комісію від і так вже у нас я на світ
переді ти ви знає ще ми бачимо про
велосипеди малювання від і вище
початкової за плоди їх не в чині раді
будуть шкоди ти за петрушки для вищих
початкові закладі
там ще овчина родопи ви на підтвердите а
я кисть від і ми вигляд молодість а адже
теологів його не я ж треба не
aggressive там навчаються та також адаптивні
мир та корупції на схема відпочинку та
університети побачите всі будуть
проблеми з яскравістю підручнику люди
намагатимуться в чайний харад
три мені такі університети в чині раді
ми рекомендуємо туди руку з валюту друг
він якості підручника про
підручнику для шків на склад нижчого
з'явилася справа там ще все одно 8 за
порада за видом ти періоду ти в мене це до
думка все-таки ціни з вини буде
державна служба вас з цього небудь
експерти ffc
олл-ін на цих засадах створи ти
граматиці об'єкт на не оч
об'єкта не експерт на такі
юридичного поля донним обмацуванням
піддавайтеся цьому ось настає eugene
ми будемо матрі такі наших урал
просвічені якраз підручником шкільний
закриття маленький кішок
децентралізація купив але я просто і
влада також поневолює ви людина
малокомплектної школи не виживуть ці
ситуації крізь існує і падаючі як ви
знає а не право в тому ще правиці було
б чистим популізмом здаватися ще ми не
будемо закривати вони які школи алина
знімаючи жодних програм із закриття шкіл
там ще ми з вини 8 pro
хіба що святі і в цьому випуску я
всі покарай мощі у нас мошкін скажемо і
там небо від h келді мало киргиз de tine
і в тему проблема проблема в тому нібито
поспішає дітей офісну святу яко ти
нам нашим педагогам і дно оплату
ось два ключові ми миємо два ключові
харчування за чай на що треба вдома так
виходить із ситуації що у нас е і keys
район д 2 а то багата
маленьких шкіл до людей утримати
мізерну зарплату і як є обожнюю буде
і красиво це можете самі викл до чого
не викладати половину половина
предметів
то очевидно чим можна подумати ти про
тещу в одному з або було б я кріс на ле
каре зосима земних мабуть плавним
меншим зусиль може бути офіс на великому
школа д також сцени орхідні і перед
кріслі передають валаку зарплату ось у
третьому солі може бути тягнусь
культурний центр як наслідок моєї but i
хороші транспорту кіба довозить дітей
готовий дуже шива слова про це можна
каже це там ми не хочемо в цьому
апараті ще у нас за братом чи кишки
Чи ми їх закриваємо та оптимізуємо
абсурд ми по ви не виходить
я кістки по свитою випробування забезпечення
наших викладати ev1 зарплату тому
треба виходить і за того ще ми хочемо
абача ти в скін цілому плані ось цьому
спеціальному плану закрити і шкіль
дима іншим і на буду відсотка можемо мало
цьому